Chỉ một giống sống đồng bằng tại thành phố Bay Tròn,
thuộc hồ tự trị tân cân,
một đua thuyền giống truyền thống của Trung Quốc để tổ chức theo những đặc biệt
phù hợp với điều kiện thử kết một đông.
Hó đặc này thu hút xử phát tâm của đứng đạo và đặc biên thằng thứ thởi
tạo điểm nhé cho các sự kiện thịt,
khả một lại tại thư vực.
Nếu chứ thuyền giống xử dụng trong của đua,
vẫn giữ hoàn thiết kể đau và đua đoài giống đặc trưng,
kém theo chống của bằng lãi,
như trong thách dài đua truyền thống trên mặt nước,
tuy nhiên, thuên được chẳng bị thêm lua các bằng ở phía dưới,
giúp dí chuyển nôn đánh trên về mặt sông đoáng măng sài.
Sài đơn năm nay của sự tham gia của hai mi đổ ở với khoảng ba trang và đồng viên,
các đua thuy đau theo thuy tức thống nhất để cào sự phối hợp và kỳ vật tập thể.
Theo bằng tổ chức,
việc đưa đua thuyền giống lên mặt bằng thương trình nèm đổi bởi hình thúc thí đau,
mà còn có phần dinh dữ,
lãn toàn giá trị và nó truyền thống,
cho mối cảnh phát triển phía khá của đau của tại Trung Quốc.